RICH MINER: Hey, all.
Rich Miner, Google Ventures.
I'm just going to
introduce David
because I've known him for, I
think, pretty close to 20 years
or so.
I'm excited to have
him here talking
about his book and
other projects.
He's been a sort of innovator,
entrepreneur in the Boston area
for-- well, since the early 90's
and has a multitude of degrees,
including, I think
most recently,
he was sort of both
at MIT Media Lab
and also at Harvard
[INAUDIBLE] and got a masters.
But he'll give you
more of his background.
From my perspective,
I think I first
started seeing David
around-- taking
real notice around the time of
Ambient-- welcome, come on in.
For me, he really
caught my eye when
he was doing the work at
Ambient Devices, which
was, I don't know, his second
or third startup out of five
or six.
But his ability to
combine beautiful objects
and information in the
most unbelievably simplest
terms absolutely
caught my imagination
and started to make
me realize just how
you can cook down incredible
amounts of information
into common, everyday
objects that are around you.
And I'm interested in hearing
what he has to tell us today
about his explorations
in [INAUDIBLE] and that
and other things
that he's been doing.
And so with that, I will
give you David Rose.
DAVID ROSE: Thank you, Rich.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for having
me this morning.
I brought you all posters.
There aren't enough books
to give out to everybody.
But they're available on
Amazon, or ask your manager.
They'll pay for them I've heard.
But Rick Borovoy
just reminded me
that one of his objects,
the nTAG conference badge,
which you wear, and it talks
to other conference badges
and seeds the conversation
with interesting things to say,
is one of the things
on the periodic table
of enchanted objects.
So have one of these.
And the meat of the talk sort of
covers some of what these are.
And so this is good
reference for later too.
But there are more at
the back of the room.
And for people that are back
in the lodge living room,
could I ask you guys to come up?
It's more fun to have
you be part of the mix.
So today, I'm going
to try to convince you
that these black slabs, which
are doing so well for Google,
may not be the future
of how we interact
with the internet
in five or 10 years.
And to tee up the
conversation, I
want to show you a recent piece
that came out in the "New York
Times" last week-- or I guess it
was the week before now-- that
features my cute son.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Enchanted objects
are ordinary things
that have the same functionality
that they had before,
except now, they can talk.
They're connected.
These are ordinary
things that have
extraordinary capabilities.
-When we're creating
technology for the home,
really we want to
make something that's
seamless and transparent,
and as opposed to having
things sort of call out and
draw your attention to it,
make it a more
ambient experience.
-It will just continue to behave
with those everyday objects
as we do in the world.
And we can remain
focused on connectivity
between two people.
-What we're seeing now
is this proliferation
of different devices that are
moving out from the cellphone
and onto our bodies
and into the world.
-So in the middle
of our living room
is a coffee table that
has Google Earth embedded
in the coffee table.
And I just found
that having access
to this amazing,
zoomable map completely
changes how often
we talk about travel
and how often we
talk about the world
and how often we look up
places that are mentioned.
And it's nice to have this
beautiful, large reference
object sitting in the
middle of our living space.
Our devices can
be a lot simpler.
And the interaction to
them can be a lot simpler.
The internet-connected
umbrella can just
be an umbrella that only shows
whether it's going to rain.
You don't need to tap on
an icon or do anything
that seems sort of artificial.
-We come from a time
in which we need
to adapt to our homes, and
not the other way around.
So what if our home
could be a platform
that we personalize
and we customize?
The key is how do we create this
ecosystem, these technologies
that allow us to move
from one experience
to the other in the most
seamless, most magical way.
-Some people might think that a
connected home is overwhelming,
that there'll be so much
information in a connected home
that it's just a
cacophonous environment,
and you wouldn't
want to live there.
But I think about how we
decorate our homes today.
We put photographs everywhere.
We put paintings up.
We put Post-It notes up.
There's a lot of decoration
and adornment in the home.
And I think if
enchanted objects can
be designed in the
right way, we're
going to want hundreds
of them around us.
-I think what we're going to
see is a new Renaissance where
designers as well as
computer scientists
are going to really make a
really big impact in the type
of technology that
we see in the home.
-The history of computers has
mostly been about efficiency.
I think one of things
that's changing
is that enchanted objects
can be about adding motion
and add magic to the fabric
of our everyday lives
and experiences.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: Isn't he cute?
AUDIENCE: What is
with the watches?
DAVID ROSE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: You have two watches.
DAVID ROSE: Oh, one is
called a Road-- what is it?
It's an identification band
that shows your blood type
and that sort of thing.
Road ID, that's what's called.
Road ID.
So this can be interactive.
You can ask me questions.
I'm used to teaching, so if
you're controlling the room,
I will intimidate you.
The first enchanted objects
project that I worked on
was this project out of the
Media Lab, probably in 1994.
And I had a company
called Interactive Factory
at the time.
And we worked on the DVD part
of the LEGO robotics Mindstorms.
The project was to take
computation and sensors
and put it in LEGO bricks.
And I thought, even
then, boy, if you
can reduce the size--
this was the size
of the brain of the thing.
But now, it could probably
be done for about this size.
And I just thought,
wow, if you look
at the trends in
computation and in sensors,
and you can do it at
the cost of embedding it
in plastic like this,
it's going to change toys.
But it's also going to change
everything and our interaction
with everything.
So just so you don't
have to read the book,
here's the four parts.
The first part of
the book is about-- I
try to draw a distinction
between four very different
futures and try to draw
sort of the brightest
line possible between what I
call the terminal world, which
is sort of what people
assume will be the future.
This was a Microsoft vision
video you may have seen.
What's interesting to me about
the vision that Microsoft
brings-- and to
some extent, Google
has made other investments.
But the assumption is that
there will be more screens
and they will have more gesture,
but that our interaction
with them will be sort of the
same as what we have today.
It will be a call and
response interaction.
They will be waiting for
us to do something to them.
And that requires a lot of our
attention and demands-- I mean,
these are very seductive objects
that we can fiddle with all day
long and be blue-faced
as we walk down the road.
And in some ways, that's sort
of the problem with these-- is
how much attention they demand.
And to me, there are
market incentives
that keep this terminal
world in place,
because there's a
wonderful advertising
mechanism that loves pixels.
And so the more we
can sort of project
and cover the world
and our kitchens
and everything with
pixels, the sort
of more of a built-in
advertising model that is.
Now, the second
future that I talk
about is to really, instead
of locating technology
and these convergence
devices, is
to locate technology
on and in ourselves.
And this is the
fantasy of superpowers.
The difference between
Superman and Iron Man
is that anybody can wear
one of these suits, right?
You don't have to be
born with superpowers.
You can inherit them
by putting on the suit.
And I think this is
obviously transformational
if you're an amputee or
getting a [INAUDIBLE] implant.
It does seem to be
problematic as we
put these things on our faces.
And how many people have
read "The Bubble Filter"?
It's a book about how the more
that we have personalisation
technology and the
more that we have
collaborative
filtering technology,
the more we'll all have our
own privatized view of media.
And so there will be
no consensual news.
There will be no consensual view
of what we see in the world.
And that's what I feel
like is the biggest
problem with
wearables like Glass
is what happened with audio
in the '80s where we're
all sort of jamming
on our own Walkman,
and you couldn't really
talk to anybody on the bus
because they were all in
their own audio space.
Now, if everybody's in
their own visual space,
it will limit
sociability in some ways.
So I talk about that problem.
Now, another very
distinct place that you
might locate technology
is not in and on yourself,
but outsourced.
So the outsource model is
the social robot model.
And this has been the fantasy
forever of human computer
interaction, right?
Wouldn't it be awesome if
they just spoke our language
and gestured our gestures?
And if God made us in
his image, or her image,
shouldn't we be making
tech in our image?
This is-- of course, right?
Now, I think of this as
sort of the Downton fantasy,
which is you have your people.
You've got somebody
for everybody.
You've got the person
who cooks for you,
who dresses you, who
teaches you all embedded
in different
agents, if you will.
And the more that these
agents can look like us
and reflect our
emotional states and have
their own emotional state,
that will accelerate how much
we bond with them.
So this will be much
more powerful than iPads,
because they'll
have eyes, right?
And they'll be maybe beautiful.
And maybe they'll have what
psychologists call neoteny,
which is the childlike
characteristics of cats
and dogs and Japanese anime
are really attractive to us.
And we immediately glom on to
these big eyes and big head
proportions.
And they will accelerate
how much we bond with them.
One of our colleagues
at the Media Lab
has created this dieting robot
that sits next to your fridge
in your kitchen and has
you enter what you eat.
And it would be an
iPad, except it's
sitting inside the Teletubby
belly of Autumn, which
has these beautiful,
big, giant blue eyes.
And so you feel like
bonded with this thing.
And you feel more guilty
the more [INAUDIBLE] you
have after 11:00.
And just last week, Cynthia's
group announced this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is your house.
This is your car.
This is your toothbrush.
These are your things.
But these are the
things that matter.
And somewhere in
between is this guy.
Introducing Geebo, the
world's first family robot.
Say Hi, Geebo.
-Hi, Geebo.
DAVID ROSE: How many
people have seen this?
-Geebo helps everyone
out throughout the day.
He's the world's
best camera man.
By intelligently tracking
the action around him,
he can independently
take video and photos
so that you can put
down your camera
and be a part of the scene.
-Geebo.
Take the picture.
[CAMERA SHUTTER]
-He's a hands-free helper.
You can talk to him, and
he'll talk to you back.
So you don't have
to skip a beat.
-Excuse me, Ann.
-Yes, Geebo.
-Melissa just sent a reminder
that she's picking you up
in half an hour to
go grocery shopping.
-Thanks, Geebo.
-He's an entertainer
and educator.
Through interactive
applications, Geebo can teach.
-Let me in, or else I'll--
-Huff.
-And I'll--
-Puff.
-And I'll blow your house in.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: So I guess I would
argue that he's cute, right?
He's getting there, right?
And he is sort of a
convergence device, right?
He reads to you.
He talks to your mail.
He orders pizza.
He does everything, which sort
of is on the same path as her,
which leads us right into the
uncanny valley of the more we
come closer to human-like
characteristics,
the more we're creeped out by
the technology we just made.
And it becomes this
gollum or something else
that we don't want
to spend time around
because it threatens
our own humanity.
It threatens our own
humaness the better we
are at making these
things, which takes us
into "Blade Runner" and
lots of other fictions
that have foretold of that
uncanny valley problem.
So in the book, I argue
a fourth future, which
is neither convergence nor
on us nor personalitied,
is enchanted objects.
And these are things
like-- I don't know.
My exemplar from the
cover of the book
is the Ambient Umbrella,
which was inspired by Frodo.
Who knows what Frodo did?
Todd?
TODD: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID ROSE: Who knows
what Frodo's sword,
what the capability was?
Adam?
ADAM: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID ROSE: No, this one.
ADAM: Something with orcs.
DAVID ROSE: Orcs, right.
Orcs, right.
So Sting was a sword
that was both sharp
and sort of the
perfect size for Frodo.
But it also anticipated
its own use, right?
It knew when orcs were nearby
and it would warn you of that.
So it had a personal affordance.
It was a feed forward
affordance, right?
It was like tool
tips, like you'd
roll over-- it
anticipates its use.
So the Ambient Umbrella
does that with rain.
So the little LED is
sprinkle because it
has a pager chip in the handle
that gets data from AccuWeather
and signals when you're
on your way out the door.
So this is a dialectic
between a fictional story
and a real invention.
And I'm really interested
in these dialectics
because it really answers
the question of how
are we inspired to
make what we make.
And the book goes
through a series
of examples of
these stories that
run in all of our bloodstreams
about these different objects
or these different
play patterns.
So I mean, one of
those from Grimm
is to look at the
surface of a mirror,
and say, well, it's already
a narcissistic surface.
But you could make it
even more narcissistic
if it has even
more capabilities,
like this project.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: So this
shows her recent self,
the last thing she tried on.
So she can do sort of a compare
and contrast at Nordstrom's.
It also can slow
down the video so you
can see your ass as you spin.
So another enchanted
object, which
is both a normal thing
that works as a thing
but then has this imbued
extra intelligence,
is this Anoto pen.
Has anybody tried an Anoto yet?
So it's a pen.
And it writes on
anything, just has ink.
But it also has a
microphone inside.
And it will record the lecture.
And then if you write
on special paper,
it has a camera that
looks at the dot
pattern of the special paper.
So it will record every gesture.
And the sort of magical thing is
that it associates the lecture
with the gesture.
So if you want to get back
to the point in the lecture
where it was interesting
or confusing,
you just tap your
notes there and it
starts playing the
audio right there,
which is sort of cool, right?
But then it's also a pen, right?
It doesn't have to be
this bizarre other thing.
It can sort of start and
end with being itself.
Or these trash
cans, which you all
know around Cambridge, which
are both trash cans physically.
But then also, they
compact the trash.
And then they only
tell the trash truck
to come when they're
full, which reduces
a lot of high cost labor waste.
So the poster you
have in your hand
goes through these
six aspirations
that we've had that are revealed
through fairy tales and stories
and pop culture that we've
had forever and sort of
tries to line up both
things we might imagine
and also real things
that have been
built in the Internet of Things
according to this structure.
Any questions so far?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One interesting
thing with mobile devices
is someone recently published a
picture internally that said, I
took the Android interface and I
took away all the anachronisms.
And what he did was
he took the wall clock
and replaced it with
a picture of a phone.
And he took a book and replaced
it with a picture of a phone.
He took the headphones
and replaced it
with a picture of a phone.
All these objects
that were designed
for a particular sensory motor
way of getting information
were replaced, because now
we don't use that thing.
We use our phone for that.
And so the set of
idioms that you
could refer to to guide
people's expectations of what's
going to happen are
actually shrinking.
DAVID ROSE: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: We had
this [INAUDIBLE].
We launched a newstand product.
And there's supposed to
be a stylized picture
of a rolled-up newspaper.
But a lot of people don't know
what a rolled-up newspaper
is because that's a way
of getting information
that's just not useful anymore.
How do we add idioms
back so that there
is a space of
expectations rather than
just tracking all the time.
DAVID ROSE: Right, like after
skeuomorphism goes away,
and you don't have any
of these reference icon.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, right.
Well, in some ways, I'm railing
against the putting everything
in your phone and
sort of arguing
that if you spread information
and services thinly
throughout your
environment, that'll
be a more naturalistic
interface.
AUDIENCE: Do you that there is
a way to actually still create
richness though and a learning
thing, like there's actually
something still to
teach your kids.
It's not just that they come
with all their expectations.
What does that light
on your umbrella mean,
might still be a question
that needs an answer--
DAVID ROSE: Not really.
I mean, the light
on the umbrella
is sort of-- what I
like about that example
is you don't really have to
ask the question of, well,
which app are you in right now?
And which mode are you in?
It's modeless.
And so it just does its thing.
And it does it in the
perfect decisional moments
of when you're passing it.
And so why tell you
about the weather
on the news or any other time?
Don't put the weather
in the mirror,
because what are you going to do
about it when you're dressing?
Put it right in the moment
where you need the information.
AUDIENCE: Is there enough
information though,
in that umbrella cap?
It's very simple, right?
DAVID ROSE: Right.
AUDIENCE: What if it's
going be high wind
hurricane versus drizzle?
One would call for the umbrella.
The other one wouldn't.
DAVID ROSE: Right.
Well, I do think you
can think about sort
of the design of information
as this pyramid where
at the very highest level, you
have to answer the question of,
is it worth my attention?
Even as a manager,
you're sort of like,
what's worth my attention now?
And then once you
answer that question,
then you can get more
details about well,
why is it worth my attention?
And tell me more.
But I think what's mostly
missing from interfaces
is just answering that very
high-level, most-summarized
question of where should I
be allocating my attention.
Because just think about--
remember voice mail systems
when you had to go check and
see if you had any voicemail,
and it took time to even
just answer that question,
much less the question of, are
any of them critical right now?
So that's that.
Let me offer some more examples.
And these are both
really good questions.
And I don't want a
short shrift them.
But let me-- inspired by
"Dorthy and The Wizard of Oz"
and the crystal balls and sort
of the ability for crystal
balls through fiction to show
not only information quickly
but also to foretell
the future, in 2001,
I invented this
ambient orb device
which would show anything
you cared to track.
So it really didn't have
the same affordances
of the umbrella, right?
You didn't know what
it was tracking.
It might be tracking weather.
It might be tracking
pollen counts.
You go to a website and set it.
You may be tracking whether
it's too windy or too calm
to sail your boats,
wherever your boat is,
or the first derivative
of barometric pressure,
or how your garden's
not growing or--
But all of those
were information
that could packed
into one pixel.
Because you could sort
of one-dimensionalize
the information and be
able to really see it out
of the corner of your eye.
And the magic of that device
was just how little attention
it required.
It didn't ever feel like
you were overwhelmed
with information
around the house.
And the company today,
Ambient Devices,
is doing this product, which
is the Energy Joule, which
is being sold into
power companies
to try to help people understand
how much energy they're
consuming in the house and
what the price of energy is.
And as the price of energy
changes in more dynamic energy
priced markets, that helps
reduce brownouts and reduce
new plant construction
and spinning up
dirty diesel plants and all
kinds of other goodness.
And this has two levels
of reading-- sort of back
to your question, Keith--
which is it both shows you,
at a glance, what the status is.
And then you pick
it and it shows
you the details
of how many cents
you're paying for
mid-peak power right now
and how much the--
so it sort of is
a drill-down device in
itself, although I think it
would be more elegant to just
make it an NFC or Bluetooth LE
sort of thing so that you
just tap your phone on it,
and then it gives you the
[INAUDIBLE] information
on your phone rather than
having to have a screen on it.
So for telepathy, one
of my favorite examples
is this issue of
understanding where
your family is and their state,
or the state of your team,
like who's where and
who's working on what.
People have made
maps that allow you
to track the status
of your family
on a map, which always
feels completely intrusive.
And even if you're
not having an affair
and you love them,
even then, you really
don't to be tracked on a map.
So the Weasley Clock
is sort of cool,
because it just shows
you the status of people.
It doesn't show
you exactly where
mortal terror is-- mortal peril.
It just shows you that
they are in mortal peril.
And when I was a
kid, my parents would
play this LP of
"Peter and the Wolf"
where every character in the
story has a different ringtone.
And it was sort of
a neat idea that I
took to generalize this
idea of a doorbell.
So our location-based system
that we have in our house
is as each family
member is on their way
home at the end of the
day, the doorbell plays
a ringtone for her when she's
about that-- 10 miles out, one
mile out, or very close to
home, which just gives you
this sort of breeze of presence.
It's audio only.
And it's nice to know.
It's reassuring and
calming and keeps me
from texting when
I'm on my bike.
Objects for safekeeping
are the next category.
This project I especially
like at the Media Lab
because it embedded the
sense of how close you
are to blowing through
your monthly budget-- which
is, I suppose, a way of
somebody taking care of you--
by changing the spring tension
on a hinge in your wallet.
So as you get closer to blowing
through your monthly budget,
your wallet's like [GROANS].
It's harder and harder to open
it, which is great, right?
Because there's no
screen in sight.
It's an it's a gesture
you do 30, 10 times a day.
And it's almost subconscious.
It can communicate
this information to you
in a way that's almost below
the conscious threshold.
There are other objects that
are obviously for safety
that are becoming
connected, which
I'm excited about because
they allow you to rent out
your house to other Airbnb
strangers more easily
without showing up.
I want to talk a little
bit about the fantasy
of immortality given to
us by fountains of youth.
DAVID ROSE: There's
a beautiful project
by Hiroshi Ishii
at the Media Lab
called-- I think maybe
inspired by rubbing a bottle
and having a wizard come out.
Or having-- who came out of--
the genie came out of the lamp,
right?
So these are just these
beautiful glass bottles.
And when you open them,
when you uncork them,
you unstop them,
the music emerges,
or at least that
instrument emerges.
So it's a jazz trio,
and you can cork them.
I don't know that you'd want one
of these to play with all day.
But it's a great demo.
And it's really evocative of
how you can bake information
into an ordinary,
everyday gesture.
This inspired my
most recent company,
which is called
Ambient Vitality, which
did an internet-connected
pill bottle cap.
So we sort of assumed
we weren't going
to change pharmacy workflow,
and we just used the amber pill
vial that 3 and 1/2 billion
scripts are distributed
in these things in
the US every year.
And then we just implemented a
little sensor LED and speaker
into the cap.
And I think the key thing to
the success of this product
was actually its subtlety.
So it lived most of its life
in the sort of barely nudging
you land of ambientness, right?
So it would, rather than beeping
like your microwave beeps,
which is totally
annoying-- I would
love to have all beeping
eliminated from my life.
It would start out
by just pulsing
with light really subtly.
And there was an
ambient puck on the wall
that also pulses with light.
It's almost like the
perfect butler, you know?
Because he's like
[CLEARS THROAT]
And then you realize it's
time for your next meeting,
and you don't even credit
whoever the other person is.
So there's a lot of
design space down here
in the sort of
pre-conscious-- like scent
and subliminal sound
effects like white noise,
or the change in
temperature of something--
that happens even before you get
through to ambiance or apparent
or obnoxious.
But I think designing
objects that
have that sort of smooth
curve to them is good.
So we did have a
trial with partners,
with Mass General Hospital.
And the control group-- this
is days, and this is people.
And pink means they
didn't take their med day.
So this is what normal
pill-taking behavior
looks like.
And then we turned on
all these subtle prompts.
And this is what the
intervention group looked like,
so a huge change in
pill-taking behavior,
which is good for
pharmaceutical companies
because they sell a
shitload more pills.
It's good for insurers
because people
don't go to the
hospital as much.
It's good for people too because
they don't reject livers.
And AT&T loves this, because
there are a lot more pill
caps sold than cars
or other things you
might put cell phones into.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: This was a national
campaign that AT&T did.
-In here, video games are
not confined to screens.
In here, medicine talks to you.
DAVID ROSE: And dogs,
there are a lot of dogs.
So it's a good
connectivity opportunity
for connectivity with dogs.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: And then
we were parodied
by Colbert, which
is a high point.
As you've probably
noticed, there
are many, many objects that
are internet-connected that
attempt to track our
sleep and mood and stress
and food and activity.
A couple of ones that you
may not have seen-- I'm
an adviser to a
little company that's
doing this little button.
It should be half the size,
but it's called the SunSprite.
And it's for people that have
seasonal affective disorder.
So it makes sure
you get enough sun.
And it's remarkable
for only one reason.
I mean, it's a little
Bluetooth device
and has a nice app
and everything,
but you'd expect that.
But there are two
solar panels on it
so you never have
to charge it, which
just seems like it solves a
really important problem on all
these wearable gadgets
like the Jawbone UP.
I'm always like,
oh, is it charged?
Is it not charged?
I end up feeling--
AUDIENCE: Unless--
DAVID ROSE: What?
AUDIENCE: Unless you
don't get enough sun.
DAVID ROSE: Right, right, right.
If you don't get enough
sun, then it dies, right.
And then you're depressed too.
But I feel like
these things need
to harness parasitic
power off of motion
or off of sun in order to care
for us rather than us always
caring for them.
This other project also
from [INAUDIBLE] group
at the Media Lab was
a fork that tries
to make you eat less
quickly for people
who sort of shovel it down.
And it was commercialized
through this other company
called Happy Fork.
And the feedback loop
here is interesting.
Because as you eat
too quickly, it
introduces a little bit
of palsy so you sort of
don't hit your mouth as often,
which it's such a stupid idea.
I can't believe anybody
would want this.
But you know, I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: If they
got the opposite--
my mother-in-law has
Parkinson's and--
DAVID ROSE: Oh, right.
It would dampen.
It would dampen her palsy.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
How many people have seen this?
The Vessyl Cup.
Do you do how they're doing
like the mass spectrometry
tech in the bottom of the cup?
I really don't get that.
But apparently it
differentiates between Diet Coke
and Diet Pepsi.
It knows exactly
what's in the cup
and then can measure how
much and how often you drink.
So it really solves this very
hard, quantified self-problem
of what are you eating, right?
Because no one's willing to
log it on an app consistently.
And so this is one approach.
As long as you're going to
have your chardonnay out
of this cup, it's OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID ROSE: I did, yeah.
Colbert has a really good one.
So this fantasy of
flying, of course,
is in the ninth century, "One
Thousand and One Nights,"
the fantasy of a magic
carpet, was imagined.
We don't quite have flying
cars yet or self-driving
cars, at least for purchase yet.
How many of you guys
have a self-driving car?
Don't you get them here?
No?
That's not a perk?
Should be a perk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID ROSE: Right, that's true.
This project called
the Copenhagen Wheel
makes your commute at
least a little bit easier--
maybe less sweaty if
you're a biker-- by baking
in a battery and electric
motor into the wheel
so that as you pedal harder,
it gives you more power.
I like the architecture
of this where
you can take your old bike
and just put a new wheel on.
You don't have to
buy a whole new bike.
It's sort of like the
parking meters in Brookline.
They just took the tops off
and put the credit card machine
on the top of the old meters.
I just thought that was
great that they didn't
have to like redesign
the whole meter.
It had to the
right architecture.
I'm going to fly through
another one just quickly.
So the last category
is expression.
This is maybe the
most interesting.
I talk in the book about
LEGO and about "Guitar Hero."
I really like scaffold
that supports creativity.
And this magic paintbrush
is one of those things.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: Nice, huh?
So another form of
expression is photography.
And I've been a photographer
and taking photos forever.
How many people have tried
a life-logging camera?
Anybody worn one?
So this is a product by
Narrative, a Swedish company,
successful Kickstarter.
I wore it for about three weeks
until I put it in the laundry
or lost it or whatever.
But I'll show you the results.
So it's about an inch and a
half by an inch and a half.
It takes a photo automatically
every 30 seconds.
And it has a GPS also, so it
stamps where the photo's taken.
And then you get this
digital portrait of your day,
like a little flip
book of your day.
And I'll show you one.
This is a little bit
revealing, but let's see.
Oh, here are two.
So I sped it up about 300
times so you could see.
This is one at MIT.
This is one in Copenhagen
teaching a workshop.
That's a magician that I
was able to teach with.
Sorry, I didn't
mask out any faces.
But I mean, obviously
this isn't designed
to be shared at a
conference or a talk.
It's designed to help you
see things about your day.
And I think it
does reveal things,
like just as you scan
through, how many people
did you interact with?
How sociable where you today?
How many times did you snack?
How many times did
you look at your phone
while you're at the
playground with your kids?
How often did you get outside?
It's sort of if you could
look at the metadata
from all of these photos, it's
a pretty revealing picture
of how we live.
So my most recent
company is just
about extracting
metadata from photos.
And I know Google sort of has
an interest in this as well.
But I just want to
give you a quick demo.
We're training our system
on classifiers for patterns,
primarily because most
of the money's in brands.
So brands want to know
how are people using
my products and where and
with what other things.
So let's see.
So this is a real time feed from
Twitter, Tumblr, and Instagram.
I'm sorry.
There might be porn.
I don't control that.
So we can select a category,
like faces or text extraction
or retailers.
Or let's just do liquor.
That's going to be fun.
So we can find-- these are
the "in the wild" shots of how
people are portraying liquor
brands through photos.
So liquor brands
obviously love this
because they want to
know what are the usage
occasions for the
product, who is using it.
And then they can learn more
about building audiences
and targeting ads.
They're coming
from public sources
from the biggest public feeds.
So we have a deal
with-- we're processing
all of Tumblr photos,
which is 120 million a day,
about a third of Twitter
in the US and about 5%
worldwide, and then Instagram.
So it's this huge trove
of photos and 300 servers
that we're paying Amazon
a lot of money for.
I mean, I just think it's
interesting from an Internet
of Things perspective
because cameras are ending up
being such a cheap way
of sensing things, right,
like probably the next
version of the Nest
will have a camera in it,
not just to do motion,
but to figure out who's home,
if people would tolerate it.
So in the third part
of the book, again,
I sort of try to pick
a fight with a phone
and talk about what are the
sort of inherent abilities
that's spreading services and
information thinly around us
have as opposed to on
convergence devices.
So we talked about
glance ability,
gesture, things can be maybe
more affordable, more wearable,
more indestructible-- like the
Facebook coffee table-- more
usable because the interaction
be simpler and more lovable.
I recently did a
workshop in Copenhagen
at the Copenhagen
Interaction Design institute.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: And this
is one of the concept
videos for interactive shades.
So they know that
you need masking
so they move by to
respect your privacy.
And then they open
if you're not around
because you'd like
more light in the room.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: So you get the idea.
So one of the projects
that I thought
would be especially
interesting to you is just
this question about if you
have internet of things
and the programmable world,
how might you control that?
How might you program that?
And I think AR is one of
these technologies that
allows us to see what is
programmable and interrogate
and manipulate what
is programmable.
So this is a project where
you saw a light switch,
and here, a speaker,
where you can look through
with an augmented
reality interface
and pick the set of
stations that you
want to put on this
nine-switch dial.
And then once you've done that,
you've picked the nine stations
that you like, and you don't
have to use AR ever again
on your radio.
But you now have programmed
it, so those nine stations
are the nine stations that
you want to toggle between.
So it's sort of answers
this question of-- oh,
and this is drawing
a relationship
between one speaker
and another speaker.
And so you sort of get the idea.
But I thought that would
be an interesting-- it
does require something else
of the devices in our life
though, whether they're
enchanted or not,
which is they have to be
legible to the computer, right?
So the computer vision system,
as an industrial designer,
you're no longer designing
beautiful objects for people.
But you're designing things
that have barcode-ness
so that they're
differentiated for the robots
to be able to see, right?
Like the speaker had to
have that unique pattern
so the system could
say, oh, that's David
speaker in his house.
And then it becomes
addressable by the machine.
So one last framework in
the part three of the book
is to think about
how does something
go in a stepwise fashion between
being inert, like a trash can,
and being connected and then
personalized and then sort of
play a part in the social
web, maybe gamified,
and then have a story
that engages you.
And as I'll show you
in the last video,
we hacked a trash can and
made it the Amazon Trash Can.
And as you throw things out
in the Amazon Trash Can,
there's a camera that
recognizes what's thrown out
and proposes it onto
your Amazon Fresh list
because you might want
more of that thing.
But as soon as we
built the prototype,
we realized what an
opportunity-- as you
throw something out, what
an opportunity to not just
have coconut water again
shipped all the way from Asia,
but to have the
trash can propose
like a more
locally-sourced thing
or give you shit about
like third box of cookies
this week, like, are you sure?
Are you sure you
want to do that?
So our fiction was
like it's Oscar
who's living in the trash
can who's giving you feedback
or a hard time about what he
might be reordering for you.
Or out of season strawberries,
why not try something else?
So the last part of the
book talks more about
what happens when you have
many of these things that
can talk together, and they
can all collude on your behalf.
And I've been recently
wearing the Jawbone UP.
Have other people
tried this one?
Seems like the
Brookline social network
is all into Fitbits
rather than Jawbone.
But anyway, my UP
connects to If This
Than That, which allows me to
write these one sentence rules.
How many people know IFTTT?
Most people IFTTT.
So I can set my
lights to-- recently
what I've done with the
lighting in my house
is it glows that sort of
Virgin Airlines purple
if I reach 10,000.
So like my home looks cool
if I've done the right thing.
But it's nice because it sort
of is a feedback device that's
social that my family sees.
But you can start to associate
one sensor with another sensor.
And I want to show
you one other concept
video from the Copenhagen
Interaction Design project
that we just did a
couple weeks ago, which
is to move the
enchantment out of the,
let's say, umbrella,
and move it into more
of the infrastructure around
us, like this was a set of hooks
that we're smarter and
knew what was on them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID ROSE: Sort of If
This Then That hooks.
So this friend is online,
because the system
knows that picture is
being hung from that hook.
And the system knows that
those running shoes are being
hung from that hook, and
it's good weather for running
outside and that it's going to
rain so that-- see what I mean?
So the location
of the technology
doesn't need to be in the
umbrella or in the shoes.
It can be on the infrastructure
around that's guiding them.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So we've talked about
lots of different scale
of different scales of
these things-- jewelry
scale, toy scale,
pill caps scale.
I just want to talk about a
bigger project, apartment scale
enchantment.
I just looked this up.
The median price per square
foot for a home in Manhattan
is $1,300 per square foot, which
means that for a $1,000 flat,
it's $1.3 million, right?
So it's a big price tag, even
if you're working here, right,
as a young person.
So there's lots of
examples that are
inspiring of how do people
choose to live in smaller,
compact spaces, either
campers or sailboats.
They do this on vacation.
People choose.
People go-- so we've
been decomposing
all of what people do at home--
like sleeping and working
and dining and lounging and
movie mode and yoga mode--
and trying to build apartments
that have transformer
tech where a 1,000 square
feet apartment can be built
in 25% of the square footage.
So rather than it
costing you $1.3 million,
it only costs you $330K
plus the money for tech.
And that gives you big
budget for transformer tech.
And so this is an apartment
that we've prototyped over
at the Media Lab that
has thickened wall,
thickened ceiling, and
thickened floor that
can hide either exercise
equipment or tables or bed
or other things that give you
sort of this holodeck fantasy.
You'd have to be
sort of neat though.
You can't have a lot of other
stuff around the apartment
because then it gets hung up.
So one other example
from part four
is this idea of embedding
feedback systems in furniture.
And this one was
done for Salesforce
where Salesforce was
interested in having
more balanced
conversations on teams.
A lot of introverts don't get
as much airtime as extroverts.
And so this started off as
sort of this floral pie chart,
if you will.
Each side of that grows
more as that person talks.
And so you get a
sense over time--
it's both something that's in
the middle of the table that's
sort of like a
decorative arrangement
but also gives you
feedback about who's
contributing more or less.
And where the product
is now is rather
than doing the
centerpiece, we just
made the whole table into
a constellation of LEDs
that are underneath
the wood veneer.
So as the person sitting
on one side speaks more,
very, very slowly over
the course of 10 minutes,
that wedge of the table
gradually illuminates.
So you can see over
20 or 30 minutes, you
get these different scenarios--
you can't really see them
here-- of some
wedges are more lit
and other wedges are less lit.
So that's mostly what
I wanted to show.
And let's see.
I don't actually
want to show this.
But I guess I would hearken
back-- one of the first stories
that I write in the book is
about my grandfather, who
had a wood shop with this
huge diversity of tools.
And when I was a
kid, he would always
say like, oh, hand me
the chisel over there.
And I'd be like, the
chisel over there?
It's sort of the same as
the chisel you're using.
And he'd be like, no,
it's very different.
It's like the blade
is slightly curved.
And the one I'm
using is straight.
OK.
So just as you--
Kevin Kelly talks
about this in "What
Technology Wants,"
which is a really good book.
But he notes that if you
look at the diversification
and complexity of
life on a coral reef
or of any mature tool set-- like
chisels or shoes or silverware
or drinking glasses-- as
these categories mature,
you have huge diversification
and specialization
and redundancy.
And that's what I
would hope that we
have in terms of our tools,
that we don't have convergence
into one thing, but we have
this huge specialization
and divergence.
And that will make our
interfaces more tangible,
like the wallet, more
haptic, more incidental,
like the Facebook coffee table
you saw on the first video.
It's there.
You can pay attention to it.
You don't have to
pay attention to it.
It's embedded in natural things.
And it's expressive and,
I think, more humanistic.
I'm happy to take questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, Todd.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
How's it going, David?
DAVID ROSE: Good.
AUDIENCE: So many of the
examples you gave, I love them.
There's a great
design sense to them.
There's a sense of
restraint among them, right?
So they do one
thing really simply,
and it's kind of
intuitive what it does.
It's natural.
Should we be confident
that that level of design
will win out in the future?
Or are we going to get
a lot of annoying things
that try to be too smart?
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, well, I
do think that the design
challenge is to make a set
of things that are doing very
little for us and not
count on one device
to have all of the services that
satisfy all of the questions
we might have about
whatever category it is.
Yeah, and I mean, I think the
service that our phones can
play is for the drill-down
of the drill-down
of the drill-down.
But they shouldn't handle
the other levels of questions
that we might ask about
most things, the more
sort of high-level stuff.
AUDIENCE: So like
the umbrella case,
how do you keep that from the
next company who comes along
and has it do 15
different things and 10
different companies--
DAVID ROSE: Well, I have control
over all these companies.
So luckily, I can
just tell them not to.
I don't know-- I
mean, it's going
to be messy and ugly and with
lots of instructive failures.
And no, I think it
really will be ugly,
like the number
of companies that
get into providing services.
I mean, if you think-- I
had a conversation yesterday
about somebody about
the luggage industry.
And he was saying like,
what should Samsonite do?
How should Samsonite
differentiate their luggage?
They've tried to differentiate
with the form, the lightness
of the case, the
wheels, the colors.
What should they do?
Well, it's sort of a
no-brainer that they
should put a Bluetooth
LE chip in the luggage
so it can tell you when it's
close to, if you've picked up
the wrong one, when
the luggage is coming.
Wouldn't that be useful?
Of course it would be useful.
And so obviously, all
luggage companies,
over the next decade, are going
to experiment with services
that change the inert thing to
a smarter service-based thing,
just because it's in their
business interest to do it.
But yeah, I'm sure
lots of people
will make lots of mistakes.
That's why it's important
to have good designers.
Hi, Elizabeth.
AUDIENCE: I think one of
the things that I just worry
about-- and I think needs
a lot more emphasis--
is the failure mode of things,
like 37Signals put out years
ago about error
messages on computers,
and I guess it's out of
print, but the same--
DAVID ROSE: 404, or 402, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, the same idea.
I mean, not to say-- this
is not particular to Google.
But when I was coming here
today, I had some questions.
And the person who answered
the phone would only give me
an email address which
spits out a boiler
plate which points
you to a forum.
But not in Chrome and not in
IE would the forum appear.
There was a server error
or a 404 error or whatever.
So I couldn't get to the forum.
So I had to sort of go around
to try to get to a person.
DAVID ROSE: What's an example
of how one of these things
might fail elegantly?
AUDIENCE: Well.
I was just-- elegantly, yeah.
Like if a pill bottle-- for
example, extending the pill
bottle, if it wasn't going
to let you take too many
and so one of its mechanisms
was to lock itself
if you've already taken
the one for the day.
But you've actually dropped
that one down the sink,
and you need it--
DAVID ROSE: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: --you know,
you need to have a way
to tell it, er, don't do that.
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, I mean,
one of the reasons why
I show the Happy Fork
is that just seems
to be only paternalistic and
no positive feedback, right?
That is only about
slapping people's hands
and not about doing the thing
that we know, from Pavlov
and everybody else,
which is what works,
is to shower attention and
positive feedback on things
when they're going well
rather than just scold
when the wrong thing happens.
AUDIENCE: I fear not being able
to get into my refrigerator
because it's giving some error--
DAVID ROSE: Right, right.
No, I do think designing for
more positive behavior is
better than trying
to lock things
that people shouldn't be doing.
I mean, a lot of
people asked us,
when we were designing this, if
we could do a locking mechanism
for medications that are
abused by babysitters
and other sort of use cases.
And we said, no, no, no.
Let's just try to get
people to take a daily med.
Let's solve that-- that problem
would be a big enough problem
to solve that we don't
have to solve the overuse
problem at the same time.
So I think picking
the problem carefully
is a good design principle.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The things that I
find interesting that the tools
that we use today are
largely interchangeable.
If I'm looking for
a pen, it really
doesn't matter what pen
I pick up, I can use it.
If, on the other hand,
I need to now use
the pen which is
listening to the world
and also has what I've
written for the last week
or whenever stored on it, it
changes that dynamic a bit.
Have you guys seen
something where
people are no longer willing
to dispose of things?
Are people no longer caring
about the $5.00 umbrella
because they now have their
$50.00 umbrella that lights up?
DAVID ROSE: Well, I think
your first question, which
is, I think, really
profound, is that I
do think one of the
trends is redundancy.
And one of the problems
with the Narrative clip
is that I only had one of them.
And then I put it in the
wash, like you would clothes.
So of course I put
it in the wash.
But I think, for the guys
who are doing the SunSprites,
I would want at least 10 of
them and to have them just
be built into
jackets and backpacks
so that if I wanted to take
this backpack today and this bag
tomorrow, I don't
have to remember
to put the SunSprite on
it, but they can just all
talk to each other.
And they can say, do
you have him today?
Or do I get him today?
So these sensors can
share data on our behalf.
And we don't have to care for
them, and they aren't precious.
And I think that will
happen, just like pens.
Yeah?
You had-- Matt,
you had a question,
and then you had a question.
MATT: Yeah, so you mentioned
that the goal is to kind of get
away from the feature-rich,
deep experience
of a smartphone into more of a
thinly spread out experience.
But the great thing
about a smartphone
that is that it has all these
apps that do different things.
But I can open up an app
and kind of instinctively
know what to do with
it, even if I've never
used that type of app before.
And it seems like
one of the issues
with this is there's a bunch
of different companies making
a bunch of different products
with different experiences.
And is there anyone trying to
create a custom home operating
system that brings that
all together so I'm not
going to my smart mirror
and doing something
and then having to learn
a completely new interface
for my smart refrigerator?
DAVID ROSE: Right, right.
That's a great question.
Should there be--
obviously, the people
that are doing operating systems
are working on design standards
for the people that make
apps so that they're
easier to learn and
have consistency.
I don't know of
anybody who's thinking
about other conventions.
I guess there's
certain companies that
are doing gesture recognition.
And they're working
on conventions
for like, what's a
dismiss gesture and what's
click gesture and
other click gesture.
But it's a great point about
standardizing the expectations
for the Internet
of Things, yeah.
But I would question
what you first
said, which is
you go into an app
and you instinctively
know what to do.
You may know to do because
you're sort of digital-native.
But compare that to
knives, the complexity.
When you pick up a knife,
that's instinctively
know what to do as opposed
to into an app and you
sort of-- yeah.
Yeah?
Oh, you had a question
back there, and then you.
AUDIENCE: I just have a
question about self-awareness
you had mentioned.
It seems like a big theme is
making the individual more
self-aware, whether it
be what they're eating,
which we agree is
something that's
very hard to do no matter how
much you pay attention to it.
But then something like
the Salesforce example,
it just seems like, to some
degree, that should just
be something that you should
recognize-- that you talk too
much and you're not letting
other people talk instead.
And why do you need something
to alert you to that?
And what's your
comment on that idea
of self-awareness
and technology?
DAVID ROSE: Well, I think there
can be too much self-awareness.
I mean, friends
have recently said,
the quantified life is not
worth living, which I like.
And I think you can have
too much quantification.
And I think you can also think
about quantified self more
in terms of sprints, and
less in terms of forever,
like the when I used the
sleep coach, the Zeo.
I used it and I got
something out of it
for about 20 days or 30 days.
And then I was really
happy to throw it away
because I felt like I had
learned what I needed to learn
and I didn't have to wear
the headband anymore.
So I do think that you don't
have to think about-- we're not
all going to quantify ourselves
in excruciating detail
forevermore.
But what was your second--
AUDIENCE: Oh, just of
the interaction of that
and how do we actually continue
to engender innate instincts--
like you said what
to do with a knife.
If we're constantly
quantifying it, how do we,
at the same time, let
people learn instinctively
how to just shut up when
it's time to shut up.
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, I
mean, I sort of-- my wife
told me not to talk
about our relationship.
Let's see.
But I would say that
with my mother, if I
wash the dishes
before I'm asked,
I get extra points, right?
I mean, we should all be
so lucky to live in a world
where can read
each other's minds
and do the perfect thing for our
spouses and our parents, right?
But the truth is
most of the time,
somebody has to say,
like, you, rub the back.
I'm not just going to know
that she wants a back rub
right then.
I'm not going to
know that she needs
me to come to the mammogram.
I'm not going to know
all of her needs.
And sometimes we need tools and
feedback to help us with that.
And I think with
conversational balance
especially, that's one of those
things to people predicatively
get wrong.
Like you ask somebody who's a--
like maybe he's an extrovert.
And you ask him,
after the meeting,
you say, what
percentage of the time
do you think you were
talking in the room?
And based on a count
of seconds, it was 82%.
And he will say,
eh, 55%, maybe 62%,
like that's about that range.
And it's like doing dishes.
It's like I do the dishes
all the time in my house.
But I probably do it
like 40% of the time,
so I do think we do need
feedback for certain things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I might be
misjudging the age of your son.
Was able to use the homescreen
of the tablet first,
or a dinner knife?
DAVID ROSE: The
homescreen of the tablet?
What do you-- well, dinner
knives are just dangerous.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: My 11 and
nine year old maybe
could have used a
dinner knife first.
My five and two year
old could definitely
launch their favorite app
on these non-intuitive slabs
before they could figure
out how to use a dinner
knife to cut their own dinner.
DAVID ROSE: Point taken, good.
No, right.
What did you think of
the Google Earth table
in the living room as sort of a
gesture-based interface that's
rich but doesn't have
a keyboard, can't look
at Facebook, can only
do one thing at a time,
but the one thing is
a much bigger screen
than an iPad and
not an app store?
AUDIENCE: The Skype
Cabinet was the one
I wanted, having young children.
Because terrible
thing about Skype
is that it's only
accessible in these devices
that also do other things.
And the two year old is
constantly, oh, there
are so many buttons here that
are not talking to grandma.
DAVID ROSE: Right.
Me too, right?
Like I can't write on a
computer for first drafts
because there are too
many other things to do.
I have to do it on paper just
because I'm distractable.
I'm like, oh, what's going
on on the internet now?
So I suffer from that too.
Hi.
Hi, Jonathan.
AUDIENCE: So,
David, [INAUDIBLE].
What is your assessment
of Google Glass?
DAVID ROSE: I think you came
in right after I showed it.
But well, I wrote in the book
that I was disappointed by it.
At first, I was
disappointed because it
didn't have a reference
to what I was looking at.
And my expectation
was that it would
understand exactly
what I'm looking at,
and like an augmented
reality application,
notice that that part of
the wall over there is free
and then put the
information right there, so
that it would have a sense--
or know that I'm talking to you
and put the name
above your face.
Or have a sense of what I'm
seeing right now as a base,
and then superimpose
information on that base, which
it didn't do and
still just floats
a screen sort of up here.
But the more I thought
about it, the more
I thought about this
problem that once we're
all wearing that and the
better version of Google Glass
does work where it's more
immersive, that there will
be this almost sociological
problem that you'll
see different things
than what I see.
And it'll intrude
on our relationship
because we will no longer
have this consensual view
of reality, that you'll decide
to filter out certain things,
and I'll decide to
filter out other things.
And then it'll be hard
to talk because you
won't be listening to my music.
And I won't be
listening to your music.
And we won't see
the same things.
AUDIENCE: Well, because I think
the whole concept of Google
Glass is it's not supposed to
interfere with your reality.
It's a stream that's off to the
side that you can look up to.
But it's not supposed to--
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, just
because of the intrusiveness
of the size of the glasses
and how much they do shield,
I find that they are a little
bit of a pariah right now.
They need to be smaller.
AUDIENCE: So I think
that actually gets back
to this conversation of this
sort of metaphors [INAUDIBLE].
Like your example
with the umbrella,
it makes sense that
the umbrella would
say it's going to rain today.
That association works.
I think the problem that
maybe you had with Glass
is that because it's
a glasses form factor,
you sort of have these
expectations based on that.
[INAUDIBLE]
You think certain things
because they're glasses, right?
You expect it to
[INAUDIBLE] vision clearer.
It sort of does.
But it sort of doesn't.
So I don't know.
I was curious.
Do you think at all in terms
of-- because these smarts,
anything could tell you
that it's going to rain.
The pen could tell you
But it's more
logical and natural
to have that be associated
with the umbrella, right?
And maybe you get
into that stuff--
DAVID ROSE: Yeah, a slide
I didn't I didn't show,
but I think-- it's a
little bit of a pie chart.
When I did a bunch of
ambient furniture pieces
at the Media Lab, the
approach that I took
was to take all of the things
that we surround ourselves with
and touch everyday, and
then all of the apps
that I use everyday,
and try to sort of make
marriages between them.
And the way that I drew the line
was to sort of interview them.
And I put the couch on
the psychological couch,
and said, cabinetry, what
are you really about?
And it said, I store things.
People just think
I store things,
but I'm really
about so much more.
I'm about discovery and surprise
and revealing things to people.
And the coffee table said,
I'm not just a low table.
But the fact that I'm low
changes the conversation.
It's more about communion
and sharing and informality.
So that becomes more
of a place for photos
rather than a work surface,
that sort of thing.
I'm not saying-- this is just my
thinking for one day about it.
But you could make
a much better chart.
Why don't you be
the last question?
Is that all right?
AUDIENCE: I think that there's
a really fine line between very
useful tools to
creepy tools, like--
DAVID ROSE: Useful versus what?
AUDIENCE: Creepy.
DAVID ROSE: Creepy, uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: --intruding your life.
And how do you know?
Because I talk to my friends,
and I get all the time,
Google knows everything.
It's kind of creepy.
And it's OK maybe, for the
active user, for those tools.
You're choosing to
use these tools,
so you kind of
assume that you agree
to all these terms of services.
But then I'm wondering for
other people in your life,
the more there are,
the tools, you never
know what it's capturing.
For example-- what is
it? [INAUDIBLE] pen?
You never know who's recording.
DAVID ROSE: Yes, right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: For
example, you'd never
know who's recording
your lecture [INAUDIBLE].
Somebody may be voice
recording everything, right?
You'd never know.
And there are so many
instances that I'm
wondering do you have any
sense of where the line is
between when it gets useful,
that people are like, you know,
he's OK, and where it gets
to be that people freak out?
DAVID ROSE: I think
almost all of these things
cast enough data off that
they're almost all creepy,
even the ones that
wouldn't seem to be creepy,
like the Nest thermostat.
It's changing your heat.
Who cares what you
set your heat at?
And who would care about
the history of how warm
you warm your house
in the winter?
But if you think
about it, that's
showing when you're
home for forever, right?
So I do think we need
privacy policies about who
can access the data.
And also, mostly we
need forgiveness.
Mostly we need an
absolution button
that says, forget everything.
So all of these
things need a button
where you can go to
the Nest website,
or even not even on the
device, and say, lobotomize.
Like you think you've
learned something about me,
and no, you haven't
learned-- I'm
somebody who's
using the apartment.
And no, you know
nothing about me.
So I do think these things
need sort of big reset buttons
to solve that problem.
And I'm actually surprised that
more people aren't creeped out
by Google reading your
email over the last decade.
That seems to cross
much more of a line
than a lot of these, like
how many steps I've walked
or that sort of thing.
So I think there's actually
a lot more potential
for being afraid
with mobile phones
than there is for a lot
of Internet of Things.
But it's spawning a new
conversation about that.
Thank you so much for coming
and for your attention.
It's really fun.
[APPLAUSE]